und meine Damen und Herren wir wollen
noch ein bisschen schauen auf die
anderen Zelte auf die anderen Ergebnisse
an diesem Vormittag 4 september im
bayerischen Abenberg oder gillamose also
das älteste Volksfest in Bayern es war
ganz interessant jetzt zu erleben man
kann natürlich die Wahlkämpfer in Bayern
wirklich jeden Tag mehrfach beobachten
aber es wäre interessant jetzt zu
erleben noch einmal wie sich jemand der
sehr im Fokus der Öffentlichkeit
gestanden hat in den letzten Tagen heute
an diesem Vormittag gegeben hat nämlich
der bayerische stellvertretende
Ministerpräsident und freie wählerchef
Hubert Aiwanger hier noch mal Positionen
aus seiner Rede
vor einem Jahr ist über diese Treppe
hier der Winnetou runtergekommen und ich
glaube
[Applaus]
und ich glaube das ist eine
symbolhafte Situation dafür was man mit
uns Freien Wählern verbindet wir haben
in einer Zeit wo es plötzlich nicht mehr
politisch korrekt erschienen
Karl May zu lesen Cowboy und Indianer zu
spielen wo eine woke Zeit ja immer mehr
auch diese Dinge
aufrollen wollte und sagte ja die Kinder
sollen immer Kaube und Indianer spielen
und da Winnetou passt eigentlich gar
nicht mehr in diese heutige Gesellschaft
der ja völligen Modernität und was weiß
ich noch alles dann wir uns freiwiller
hingestellt und haben eben diesen
Winnetou zu uns kommen lassen und haben
uns hinter diese Thematik gestellt und
haben gesagt die sind Traditionen das
sind ja
identitätsstiften die Kerne vielleicht
dafür viele junge Leute die in dieser
Zeit auf Boxen sind und die auch in den
letzten Jahren in
Faschingsveranstaltungen Taube und
Indianer spielen wollen die eine
Prinzessin spielen wollen die in den
Ölscheich spielen wollen die was auch
immer spielen wollen und ich glaube dass
wir als frei Wähler damit auch
dokumentiert haben dass wir für
Meinungsvielfalt stehen dass wir nicht
zulassen das hier die Schlinge immer
enger gezogen wird das in dieser ja
vielleicht vorgegebenen Meinung immer
mehr gesagt wird was man nicht mehr tun
denken und sagen darf und deswegen haben
wir uns hinter Winnetou gestellt wir
haben uns auch hinter das Thema Papa und
Mama gestellt und es muss ja so und es
wurde mir letztes Jahr und Weihnachten
sich eine Weihnachtskarte verschickt
haben mit Papa Mama Sohn und Tochter
drauf
angekreide dass ich hier eine
klischeefamilie
verbreiten würde den Papa Mama und zwei
Kinder und ganz böse der Kachelofen im
Hintergrund und ist Märchenbuch auf den
Knien das würde ja immer in diese Zeit
passen sondern man müsste heutzutage
andere Weihnachtskarten verschicken
meine Damen und Herren ich bin den Weg
nicht mitgegangen also es ist eben
heißen hat die Papas und Mamas heißen
auf morgen Elternteil 1 und Elternteil
zwei
die Kinder heißen nicht mehr Sohn und
Tochter sondern K1 und K2
weil man ja vielleicht sicherheitshalber
nicht weiß ob man nicht
ich sage jetzt auch die Worte und die
Stelle wenn das Kind dann 14 Jahre alt
ist und sagt ich fühle mich jetzt doch
anders als ihr mich die letzten 14 Jahre
gesehen habt jetzt lasst mal bitte mein
Geschlecht noch offen bis um 14
Lebensjahr meine Damen und Herren sehr
sehr sehr sensible Themen ich habe jetzt
überlegt ob ich das überhaupt ansprechen
will aber ich glaube man muss auch diese
Dinge ansprechen weil man einfach sehen
dass diese Gesellschaft mit solchen
Themen in eine falsche Richtung
getrieben wird natürlich gibt es viele
[Applaus]
natürlich gibt es viele und es sind wohl
einige tausend pro Jahr in unserem Land
die im Laufe ihres Lebens eben sich in
einer anderen geschlechtlichen Identität
wiederfinden wie gesagt es fällt uns
schwer über solche Dinge zu reden weil
man eben bei jedem Wort ja vielleicht
das Sorge hat jemand Unrecht zu tun ja
wir müssen das weiterhin mit sehr viel
Fingerspitzengefühl behandeln aber umso
unverständlicher ist mir eben wenn jetzt
eine Bundesregierung den Weg geht zu
sagen das ist dann durch eine einfache
Meldung beim Einwohnermeldeamt erledigt
und es könne man einmal pro Jahr ändern
also mein Verständnis ist dass wir damit
der Sache nicht gerecht werden dass wir
denjenigen die mit dem Thema
[Applaus]
die mit dem Thema vielleicht seit ihrer
Kindheit Ringen und nicht wissen in
welche Identität Sie gehen wollen gehen
müssen um am Ende ihres Lebens glücklich
zu werden ich wünsche jedem der hier im
Zweifel ist die richtige Entwicklung
dahin gehen und genau deshalb glaube ich
dass es nicht richtig ist ohne
Begutachtung ohne Unterstützung von
außen ohne Fachkompetenz Menschen in
diesem Lebensalter ja vielleicht in eine
Richtung zu drängen weil es gerade
überhaupt ist und übers Internet
verbreitet wird dann plötzlich
Geschlechtsumwandlungen vorgenommen
werden wo man paar Jahre später sagt es
war Fehler meine Damen und Herren es ist
mehr als ein Tattoo was man hier in
seinem Leben dann macht und deswegen
glaube ich einfach dass die politische
Entwicklung in unserem Land bei diesen
Dingen nicht mehr die Vernunft ja hinter
sich hat sondern die Ideologie hinter
sich hat meine Damen und Herren wenn es
um das Thema geht
der cannabis-freigabe da sehen wir es
genauso wir wollen nicht den Staub
brechen über Menschen die vielleicht mit
gewissen Mitteln sich leichter in ihrem
Leben tun und sagen ich brauche das weil
schon gar nicht die medizinischen
Bereich da sind viele Einsatzzwecke
sinnvoll aber wenn sich jetzt ein
Gesundheitsminister hinstellt gemeinsam
mit dem Landwirtschaftsminister und sie
bringen ein Gesetz auf dem Weg das
Cannabis freigegeben wird dass jeder
drei Pflanzen Cannabis zu Hause haben
soll wo dann auch Jugendliche Zugang
haben zu diesen Dingen und jeder weiß
dass er anwachsende wenn sie Cannabis
konsumieren schwer geschädigt werden
können dann ist es für mich nicht
sensibel genug bei dem Thema so
umzugehen sondern das so ganz kleinen
Gesundheitsminister müsste sich doch
dafür kümmern dass unsere Krankenhäuser
Zukunft haben und nicht geschlossen
werden und da Landwirtschaftsminister
dass unsere Landwirtschaft Zukunft hat
und etwas beide gemeinsam sich nur für
die Cannabis frei aber hinsetzen
[Applaus]
und genauso
genauso bin ich aufs Podium gegangen
also es um das Thema des
heizungsgesetzes gegen meine Damen und
Herren warum weil wir die tiefe
Betroffenheit einer überwiegenden
Mehrheit dieser Bevölkerung nicht
ausblenden konnte die sagen wenn ich in
meinem neuen Haus keinen Holzofen mehr
hinbauen darf keine Hackschnitzelheizung
mehr einbauen darf wenn mir vorgegeben
wird in den nächsten Jahren mein
Bestandsgebäude mein 30 40 50 Jahre
altes Elternhaus so sanieren und Dämmen
zu müssen dass es
wärmepumpentauglich ist ich habe 60
70-jähriger bei der Bank nicht mehr
einen Kredite über 150.000 € bekommen
ich dann wenn ich das Haus und meine
Kinder übergeben will nur 200.000 €
Erbschaftssteuer zahlen muss meine Damen
und Herren da haben wir gesagt wir
können diese Politik nicht so laufen
lassen wir können hier nicht zuschauen
wie eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
Beginn Angst versetzt wird in
Existenzangst in Zukunft sonst jeder der
im Laufe seines Lebens gesorgt hat fürs
Alter vielleicht nicht in Urlaub fahren
ist sich das vom Mund Weg gespart hat
das kleine Häuschen die Kinder in den
Ferien mitgeholfen haben das Haus neu
hinzu decken die neuen Fenster
einzubauen das Haus zu sanieren und so
weiter und dann am Ende die politische
Ansage bekommen euer Haus entspricht
nicht mehr den Kriterien du musst auf
Wärmepumpe umsanieren diese kostet 10000
€ und das Haus an ihren 100.000 € und
wenn du das nicht tust dann bist du ein
Klimasünder meine Damen und Herren ohne
Absprache ist Thorsten Glaube sagt die
mit den Fachleuten ohne Absprache mit
den Heizungsbauern eine solche
ideologische Gesetzgebung auf den Weg zu
bringen das sind wir Freien Wähler auf
die Bühne getreten und haben gesagt
liebe Leute so nicht ihr dürft doch das
Eigentum Menschen nicht kaputt machen
ihr dürft die Menschen nicht unter
Zugzwang setzen wie hatten wir Sorge im
letzten Jahr im letzten Winter als wir
fürchten mussten dass die Gasversorgung
zusammenbricht wie waren wir froh um
jeden Holzofen um jeden Hausbesitzer der
sagte naja wenn kein Gas mehr kommt wenn
ich kein Öl mehr bekomme ich habe immer
nur fünf sterbenholz und ich werde nicht
erfrieren als diskutiert worden ist dass
man sich kalt duschen muss und mit
Waschlappen waschen muss da haben wir
gesagt wir sind doch froh dass wir
solche vernünftigen Leute noch haben die
vielleicht zu Hause das Glück haben
eigenes Häuschen zu haben an eigenen
Holzofen zu haben kaum war dieser Winter
rum kommt ein Gesetzes genau diese
letzte Hilfe in Stunde der Not verbieten
will und sagt wir wollen keinen Holzofen
mehr haben meine Damen und Herren da ist
doch vieles kaputt gemacht worden da ist
doch eine Bevölkerung konfrontiert
worden mit einer Politik die immer mehr
ja so interpretiert wird die wissen
nicht was unten los ist die entscheiden
Dinge von einem heizungsgesetz und
selbstbestimmungsgesetz und so weiter
die wir vielleicht nur am Rande als
Normalbürger einordnen können und
kümmern sich nicht darum das
krankenhäuse erhalten werden das
Handwerk und Mittelstand Zukunft hat
dass der der in die Arbeit geht von
seinem Geld auch leben kann dass
Deutschland Industrieland bleibt dass
wir weiterhin bezahlbare Energie haben
und die Leute nicht das Land verlassen
und meine Damen und Herren auch ein
Beispiel was mich vor wenigen Wochen in
Schwaben zum Nachdenken gebracht hat und
was mich eigentlich bis heute ja auch
irgendwo vor den Kopf stehst da ist ein
junger Metzger auf mich zugekommen bei
einer Veranstaltung lieber Fabian ich
glaube du warst dabei auf der
Veranstaltung und hat zu mir gesagt
ich sehe in unserem Land als Handwerker
als Metzger keine Zukunft mehr ich
wandere jetzt noch Kanada aus meine
Damen und Herren ein handwerksmetzger in
Bayern der sagt er wandert weil immer
mehr Vorschriften kommen immer mehr
Ärger auf die Leute zukommt er wandert
noch Kanada aus weil er in diesem Land
keine Zukunft mehr sieht und wir haben
derzeit 700.000 Geburten in Deutschland
im Jahr und
250.000 verlassen Deutschland pro Jahr
und zwar diejenigen die gut ausgebildet
sind die Ingenieure die Ärzte die
Krankenpfleger die gut ausgebildeten
gehen aus diesem Land raus sie kehren
diese im Land den Rücken weil sie sagen
die haben die Nase voll von immer mehr
Bürokratie von immer mehr Ideologie von
immer schlechteren Rahmenbedingungen und
ich sehe sehr sehr viele junge Leute
hier sitzen sollen wir den zu diesem J
ungen Leuten sagen das war's jetzt diese
ideologische ampelpolitik wird so
weiterlaufen wir schauen weiter zu in
ein paar Jahren gibt es eben kein Haus
mehr geschweige denn das neue Häuser
gebaut werden
die Altersvorsorge wackelt die
Pflegesituation spitzt sich zu wir
werden in zehn Jahren doppelt so viele
Pflegebedürftige in Bayern haben wie wir
heute schon haben und haben heute schon
einen anbauen in den Pflegenotstand
sollen wir sagen wir schauen weiter zu
wie junge Leute dieses Land verlassen
und wir lassen die alten zurück sollen
wir weiterhin schauen wie Deutschland
die industrialisiert wird wie jedes
vierte Unternehmen in Deutschland sagt
ich mache entweder dicht oder ich gehe
ins Ausland in einer Situation wo die
Amerikaner günstigste Bedingungen
anbieten günstigste Steuern günstigste
Energiepreise wo die Chinesen versuchen
unsere Technik abzugraben wo die
Chinesen den deutschen Verbrennungsmotor
holen wollen und sagen sie wollen bis 20
60 am Verbrennungsmotor festhalten
während wir in Deutschland sagen von
2035 also nicht mal zehn Jahren soll
kein Verbrennungsmotor mehr zugelassen
werden meine Damen und Herren dieses
Land wird derzeit rückabgewickelt wir
verlieren den Wohlstand wir verlieren
die soziale Sicherheit warum weil wir
auch den inneren Halt verlieren weil
grundlegende Dinge in Frage gestellt
werden weil in Frage gestellt wird ob
Leistung sich überhaupt nur lohnt meine
Damen und Herren wenn ein Bürgergeld
Empfänger selbst wenn er selbst
arbeitsfähig und jung und kräftig wäre
genauso viel verdient wie ein
mindestlohnempfänger noch Steuerabzug
dann kann das nicht richtig sein und
dann wird es dazu führen dass die
Leistungsträger immer mehr demotiviert
werden dass sie dieses Land am Ende
verlassen wenn sie Leistung bringen
wollen
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren und wenn die
Leistungsträger das Schiff verlassen
dann wird es dazu führen dass die
verbliebenen
sozialbedürftigen plötzlich nicht mehr
die Stütze haben nicht mehr die
Steuereinnahmen haben damit wir uns
Krankenhäuser damit wir uns
Altersvorsorge damit wir uns Zorn
Behandlungen leisten können und dann
schauen Sie in Ländern wo die sozialen
Systeme nicht mehr funktionieren wo man
den Wohlstand eines Menschen und seinem
Gebiss erkennt das will ich nicht in
Deutschland ich will einen
funktionierenden Sozialstaat ich will
[Applaus]
ich will dass ich leistung lohnt und ich
will weiterhin dass es Sinn macht
innerhalb der Generationen und innerhalb
einer Familie wenn die Eltern und
Großeltern ein Haus bauen auch in
fortgeschrittenem Alter nicht mehr für
sich vielleicht auch ein Mietshaus bauen
vielleicht die Firma erweitern weil sie
wissen sie tun es für ihre Kinder für
ihre Enkelkinder aber dann brauchen wir
eben auch eine Politik die dieses
Arbeiten für die nächste Generation
honoriert und deswegen sagen wir es
freie Wähler schon seit langem an der
Stelle um Leistung und Arbeit in
Familien in Generationen zu honorieren
müssen wir die Erbschaftssteuer
abschaffen damit man ein Haus auch Erben
kann wenn sie Eltern gebaut haben
[Applaus]
und wir hatten vor einigen Wochen in
München eine Veranstaltung zum Thema
Erbschaftssteuer auch mit einem
Steueranwalt und da sind am Ende
Menschen auf mich zugekommen
Mittelständler vom flachen Land die vor
40 Jahren in München ein Mietshaus
gebaut haben als einfach in den 80er
Jahren die Dinge wirtschaftlich noch gut
gelaufen sind das ist die Grundlage
dessen dass wir überhaupt Wohnungen in
München haben und jetzt sagen diese
Leute jetzt will ich mein Lebenswerk an
meine Kinder übergeben und werde es
nicht mehr bezahlen können weil dieses
Haus heute Millionen wert ist in
Wahrheit aber noch habe ich sanieren und
wer mit dem Vorgaben ja teuer saniert
werden muss und eigentlich ein
Sanierungs vorliest und die Kinder
hunderttausende wenn nicht Millionen und
Erbschaftssteuer zahlen müssen deshalb
werden keine Häuser mehr gebaut wir
beklagen den Einbruch im Wohnungsbau und
wir stellen fest dass mieten immer
knapper werden bleibt immer teurer
werden und wenn dann die Lösung kommt zu
sagen du musst auch denjenigen die
Arbeiten die ein Haus bauen wollen auch
dazu den Mut geben und die
Sinnhaftigkeit geben und dann heißt es
nein das können wir nicht weil eine
neiddeparty verhindert dass wir dafür
Mehrheiten in der Politik bekommen meine
Damen und Herren dann müssen wir einfach
diese Dinge mal auf den Tisch legen
argumentativ auf dem Tisch legen und
dann müssen wir als frei Wähler dort
Zusammenhänge aufdecken und müssen sagen
es ist auch nicht im Sinne des armen
Mieters wenn der Hausherr sich kein Haus
mehr leisten kann wenn er sein Haus
nicht mehr vererben kann also wer hier
gegen die Leistungsträger wer gegen
Eigentum vorgeht der legt die Arzt dann
an die soziale Sicherheit dieses Landes
das führt dann zu einer politischen
Spaltung und jetzt schauen uns mal in
den allermeisten Bundesländern außerhalb
Bayern sind welche Parteien momentan
Zuwächse von bis zu 10% innerhalb
weniger Wochen hinlegen seit
heizungsgesetz und Co meine Damen und
Herren dieses Land wird derzeit
politisch tief gespalten bis hin zu
einer Situation der
Regierungsunfähigkeit wenn wir so weiter
tun wenn sie sich die
[Applaus]
wenn sie sich die Wahlumfragen in auch
ostdeutschen Bundesländern ansehen wo
die beiden Randparteien im Parteien
Spektrum miteinander über 50% haben
dann meine Damen und Herren ist die
Demokratie in höchster Gefahr und
deswegen glaube ich müssen wir den
Menschen in der politischen Mitte ein
Angebot machen ein Angebot der
vernünftigen Politik ein Angebot der
koalitionsfähigkeit ein Angebot dessen
dass wir hier verhindern dass Menschen
und die radikalen Ränder gehen und
Zeichen zu setzen um irgendwo zu
versuchen die etablierten aufzurütteln
und die sind ja häufig die Aussagen wenn
man mit den Menschen redet ja ich will
damit die mal sehen dass wir dem nicht
mehr so zuschauen und ich glaube dass
wir Freien Wähler hier diejenigen sein
die bevor hier das Kind in den Brunnen
fällt die Dinge beim Namen nennen wenn
es auch im nach kritisiert worden ist
das Hubert Aiwanger beim Thema
heizungsgesetz so aufgetreten ist und
hat diese Politik so massiv kritisiert
meine Damen und Herren ich sah mich in
keiner anderen Situation als zu sagen
wir müssen die Dinge beim Namen nennen
damit die sehen dass die Bevölkerung
diesen Weg nicht mitgeht dass man solche
wichtige Dinge
[Applaus]
dass man solche wichtigen Dinge die an
die Existenz der Bevölkerung geht nicht
eben schnell mal verkündet ohne die
Betroffenen Hausbesitzer und
Heizungsfachleute einzubinden die ist
dann schnell vor der Sommerpause
durchwinken wollte in der Hoffnung dass
die Menschen im Sommer im Urlaub die
Dinge vergessen und ab Herbst beginnt
dann die Maschinerie ab Herbst kommt an
der Heizungsbau und der Kaminkehrer und
zeigt die Leute an deren Häuser nicht
diesen Standards entsprechen mit strafan
Drohungen die ja im Raum stand von
10.000 €, wenn man sein Haus dann nicht
diesen Kriterien anpasst die sich eine
ja grüne Bundesregierung an der Stelle
erhofft ohne zu fragen ob diese Menschen
denn überhaupt in der Lage sind das zu
bezahlen nach dem Motto dann können Sie
Haus habe verkaufen wenn sie es nicht
bezahlen können dann kauft ihm jemand
anders das Haus oder naja dann legen wir
eben einen
staatlichen
unterstützungsvorhaut in Höhe von
hunderten Milliarden Euro meine Damen
und Herren wo soll denn dieses Geld
herkommen das fällt ja nicht vom Himmel